hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast evaluating the results of
animal studies by means of native
analysis presented by dr. carline
Boylan's we are excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by library for more information please
visit lab roots calm and even seen cam
of lag roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem now I'd like to introduce dr.
carline women dr. Hartman's obtained her
bio medical degree our biomedical
science degree in 2004 and her PhD
concerning the impact of nutritional
lipids and vascular effect factors in
experimental Alzheimer's disease in 2008
currently she is assistant professor at
the car boot in nitrogen and the
netherlands department of anesthesiology
and the semantic review center for
laboratory animal experimentation and
nitrogen in the netherlands her main
research interest involves the
translation of results from animal
studies into clinical practice please
join me in welcoming dr. Wyman's I'll
now turn the presentation over to her
Thank You swans thank you very much and
good afternoon everybody I suppose it's
for most people do afternoon as you
heard I'm Caroline my moms and I will
give a lecture about evaluating the
results of animals
by means of math analysis but before we
can start and talk about meta analysis
it's important to first refresh your
memory about systematic reviews so what
is a systematic review a systematic
review is a literature review focused on
a single question which tries to
identify a pre-select and synthesize all
high-quality research evidence relevant
to that question probably some of you
attended a meeting this morning from
middle it's cos so it might be that
there will be a little bit of overlap in
this presentation but to make sure that
everybody has the same background I will
tell you a little bit more about why we
should perform or why we could perform a
systematic review of an animal studies
conducting a systematic review of animal
studies helps us to provide an overview
of the available evidence but also to
identify knowledge gaps areas where more
research is necessary in addition it
could help us to identify factors
influencing treatment efficacy so
exploring a fixie of treatments last but
not least it helps us to a forum
experimental design of new animal
studies but systematic reviews can also
guide the design of clinical trials a
systematic review of animal studies
generally consists out of six steps
these steps of a systematic review of
animal studies are mainly the same as
for clinical systematic reviews of
randomized clinical trials for example
so we could learn a lot from the
experience available in the clinical
fields you start with phrasing the
research question a very focused
research question mainly consisting of
the elements animal intervention outcome
and comparison secondly you start to
search for all available evidence
preferably in two databases and you
conduct a very comprehensive search when
you finally in found all the studies you
need to select all the relevant studies
and then you can start with extract
the necessary characteristics of the
studies to comparative studies think for
example about the type of species the
gender different aspects of the
intervention like those duration timing
etc subsequently in the fifth step we
start to assess study quality and most
often we conduct a risk of bias analysis
so we look at the different levels of
randomization and blinding to reduce
selection bias performance bias
detection buyers etc finally when we
extracted to data we could analyze all
the data and if possible conduct a
meta-analysis it's important however to
realize that meta analysis is often part
of the systematic review but it does not
necessarily need to be so you can also
publish your paper or your systematic
review without a meta-analysis
meta-analysis should only be conducted
when the studies are similar enough that
I will come back to that later and then
finally if you conduct with all the six
steps you can interpret all the results
but what is a meta-analysis a
meta-analysis is in other words an
analysis of analysis so a statistical
combination of data from primary studies
but before we go on it's important to
realize that the quality of the
meta-analysis is completely dependent of
the quality of the primary studies so
rubbish in is rubbish out in order to
explain what the meta-analysis is it's
important first to understand how to
read a forest loss generally the results
of a meta-analysis are displayed in a
forest plots a forest cloth is a
graphical display designed to illustrate
the relative strength of treatment
effects in multiple quantitive
scientific studies addressing the same
question here you can see for example
for individual studies and concerning
the effects of omega-3 fatty acid
supplementation in experimental
Alzheimer's disease
these studies show the effects of
omega-3 fatty acids on neuronal cell
death in experimental Alzheimer's
disease you see the original oh it's
going a little bit faster than a clinton
you see the original data of both
experimental and the control proof so
I'll point it out to you you can see
here the original data from the
experimental group and the from the
control group the mean standard
deviation and the number of animals
subsequently you can see the calculated
effect size and the strength of the
effect here we use the standardized mean
difference and I will come back to that
later on how you calculate that the
effect sizes are depicted on the right
side as green boxes you can see that
here in cage and effect size is on the
left it means a degrees in cell death
and on the right it means an increase in
cell death the line through two boxes
represents the 95 confidence interval of
the calculated effect size of all
individual studies finally we if we look
at the example for example of the
Chinese study we see the original data
and subsequently we clearly see that the
effect size is on the left side but the
95 confidence interval includes zero you
can see that it touches that line so in
other words there is no significant
effect of omega-3 fatty acid
supplementation when finally all studies
are combined we see the results depicted
in the last line reflected as a diamond
here the width of the diamond represents
the confidence interval of the summary
effect but what are the aims of a
meta-analysis of animal studies first of
all it helps us to evaluate the efficacy
of an intervention here you can see a
similar plot as just discussed but now
some more studies are included you can
see four studies in the cortex the upper
four and then four studies in the
hippocampus when we look at the efficacy
we focus on a direction of the effect in
animal studies because studies are often
so heterogeneous here you can see that
the effect is on the left side and so it
means a significant degrees in neuronal
cell death the second aim of
meta-analysis is to explore the
heterogeneity to generate new hypothesis
design and guide new animal studies or
clinical styles in this plot you can see
how meta analysis can help to explore
heterogeneity between studies you see
the eight studies again for studies in
the cortex four studies in the
hippocampus and we can compare the
effects of these subgroups and you can
see that the effect is smaller in the
cortex compared to the hippocampus but
as mentioned before it can also help us
to inform the design of clinical trials
here you can see a study by Weaver as
well in 2012 that investigated the
effect of ischemic preconditioning on
kidney damage I'm sorry Troy current
clinical trials on remote ischemic
preconditioning in renal if gimmickry
injury are using similar preconditioning
protocols as we did in the animal
studies and namely fractionated epc
stimuli and the short delay between EPC
and index ischemia work well however our
review which you can see below in the
table table as free shows that not only
early it's beneficial but late is as
well so the current review indicates
that even though this approach this
approach of the the early form is
effective efficacy could be even higher
in the late window of protection so
future studies should use this and try
in clinical trials also the late
addition it also helps us to find new
results often because we can increase
power in an FN
and side effects or small subgroup
effects become easier detectable here
you can see the results of a review by
from domina at all and he studied the
effects of vascular adaptation during
pregnancy and he showed that the strain
of rats majorly influence the results he
could conclude based on this
meta-analysis that wistar rats
correspond more to healthy human
pregnancy and the sprague-dawley read
more to pregnancy in vascular impaired
project impaired subjects so this helps
the researchers in this case to make a
distinction between the variety of
animal models and this was really a new
result lot but at least it can help us
to visualize unnecessary duplication of
animal studies and I will show you that
on the next slide here you see the
results of your cumulative meta-analysis
in a cumulative meta-analysis all trials
are ranked chronologically and a math
analysis is conducted every time a new
trials published in this case for the
draft TPA for stroke what you can see is
that the effect was already stable in
2001 because this is again a force plot
and what you see is that each time when
the new trial was conducted to see a
summary and you see that the tail the
tail of this figure becomes stable and
what you can see that in 2001 it was
quite stable and at that time 1,500
animals were used nevertheless more and
more trials were conducted and over
3,000 animals were used by 2008 so these
animals received unethically if disabled
treatment in addition if we could have
conducted meta-analysis earlier we could
have prevented a lot of unnecessary
duplication of animal experiments but
how do you conduct a meta-analysis of
animal studies which steps need to be
taken so this part of the lecture will
be a little bit more technical here you
can see an overview of the steps and we
will discuss these steps one by one
first of all you start with checking for
homogeneity of the included studies
results may be combined if the patient's
or animals in this case intervention and
outcomes of the various studies are
sufficiently similar in order to
determine if this is the case it is
always important to collaborate with
experts from the field so use common
sense many sources of heterogeneity
especially the clinical at originated it
can be predicted in order to do so make
sure that you define strict inclusion
and exclusion criteria and not compare
apples with oranges so for example if
you know that certain species metabolize
a specific component totally different
than the other species it might be smart
only to include the species that have
the system in which you are interested
further you need to define your
subgroups a priori but I will come back
to that later in step 2 we assemble all
relevant study data in order to combine
study results we need to data from
individual studies our ingredients
however ingredients first study differ /
scale of measurement for the Potomac
outcomes such as mortality expressed for
example as a risk Rachel or up 32 you
always need the four ingredients depicts
it on the right side so ABCD which
reflect the number of animals in the
experimental group in which the
alchemist present and the number of
animals in which the outcomes was absent
and this for both the experimental and
control group as I mentioned before for
continuous variables such as blood
pressure you need to have the mean the
standard deviation and the end so number
of animals of all the individual studies
in the rest of the presentation we will
focus on continuous outcomes so if we
have the ingredients we can choose an
effect size measure and we can calculate
the effect size for each individual
study for
for continuous variables we often use a
mean difference or a standardized mean
difference but there are much more
possibilities in case of the study that
the study's measure exactly the same for
example all blood pressure in
millimeters mercury we can calculate the
mean difference on the left left side
and this is the mean of the intervention
group minus the mean of the control
group for studies with different outcome
measurements which address the same
clinical outcome so for example
different skills for measuring
neurodegeneration think of number of
cells amount of proteins which reflect
dying cells the width of the hippocampus
which reflects dying cells in
Alzheimer's disease etc then we should
calculate the standardized mean
difference the standardized mean
difference is the mean difference
divided by the pooled standard deviation
and dividing by the pooled standard
deviation converts different skills to a
common scale however it's important to
realize that the standardized mean
difference is more difficult to
interpret so you need to interpret the
number of standard deviations difference
here you can see the difference between
mean difference and standardized mean
difference depicted in the upper plot
you see the mean difference and in the
lower plot that SMD to standardize mean
difference what you see is that the SMD
differs two standard deviations but what
does this exactly mean how should we
interpret that animal studies are
however often very heterogeneous also in
units of measurements used so we often
end up with standardized mean difference
when you finally calculate it the effect
sizes of all the individual studies we
are almost ready to pull the results but
we first have to decide on the effect
model we are going to use there are two
models the fixed effect model and the
random effect model I will not go too
much into detail now but it's important
to remember that for animal studies the
fixed effect model is is not appropriate
to make it clear so use the random
effect model when we use the fixed
effect model we assume that there is one
true effect which all studies try to
estimate in other words all the studies
measure exactly the same and differences
between individual studies are only due
to sampling variation in the random
effect model we assume that the true
effect varies from study to study and
the summary effect is our estimate of
the mean or average of effect sizes so
in other words to try it as well so
besides sampling variation there are is
also real between study variation and
this is taken into account in a random
effect model so in animal studies for
example we can expect between study
variation we expect that the true effect
of an intervention varies for example
between species so we need to take this
into account so it's not necessary that
you remember it is all but the main
thing is do not use the fixed effect
model here you see differences in
calculated effects depicted in two plots
if we for example use the fixed effect
model above when we should have used a
random effect model in the lower graph
we will encounter some problems the
confidence interval the summary effect
becomes too small for example it's a
little bit more narrow and the effect
estimate might not be correct as well
you can see here that it's a little bit
larger in the fixed effect model so you
need to take to be aware of this so when
we finally chose to random effect model
it's time to specify the subgroups so
explore at unity of the variety of
studies we include in our example is
what the amount of neurodegeneration
involved the cortex and the hippocampus
if you remember so subgroups are subsets
of trials or experiments you can also
have young or old animals works
and are especially important in
meta-analysis of animal studies because
of the explorative character of animal
studies we often include quite
heterogeneous studies and are interested
in which factors influence the effect of
an intervention it's important to
realize that post hoc subgroup analysis
so post analyst analysis which are not
predefined or meter regression can be
misleading so you need to handle them
with care be and that is mainly because
of false positive results as a
consequence of multiple testing at step
7 we finally calculate the summary
effect size to do this we need the
individual effect size and the
confidence interval and the weight of
the individual studies the pooled
estimate is calculated by multiplying
the estimate of the individual study by
the study wait so the mean difference
multiplied by the study wait so take the
sum of all the individual studies and
divide the total by the total amount of
weight the weight of a study is one
divided by the variance of the estimates
so in general this means that as the
variance of the study decreases the
studies of the larger so larger studies
receive more weight in the meta-analysis
in the random effect model there are
some changes in the calculations of the
weight which you can see in blue we do
now not only include the variance within
the studies but also the variance
between the studies as I explained with
the figure before so in the random
effects model two types of variation are
included random error so sampling error
andreu between study differences and
this is exactly why we use two random
effect model generally in animal studies
because as against consequence of nature
of the animal studies we often have
between study differences finally we
need to interpret our results so let's
take a look at this figure again
remember the figure and we need to
interpret at least the effect size the
confidence interval and the extent of
heterogeneity in this case we have an
overall effect size of minus 1.7 and the
confidence interval varying from minus
2.7 to minus 0.8 this indicates that
omega-3 fatty acids significantly
because the 0 is not included in the
confidence interval degrees is the
amount of neurodegeneration in
experimental animals with regard to
heterogeneity between salivary soda
between fella variation we see an I
squared of seventy-three percent percent
this means i squared of seventy-three
percent that seventy-three percent of
the total amount of heterogeneity is due
to between study variations so due to
real differences between studies but I
will come back to that later but what is
heterogeneity heterogeneity is excessive
variation in the results of studies
there will always be variation in the
results but that is normal that's due to
sampling error with excessive variations
we mean more than we expect due to
random sampling error and this may be
caused by clinical heterogeneity and so
differences in population differences in
the methodology and unknown sources so
and we call that unexpected edgenuity
the amount or extent of heterogeneity
can be estimated you can see here a
calculation and one measure is the i
squared I mentioned before here you see
the formula and if their determines the
amount of between study heterogeneity so
the total amount minus the expected
amount divided by the total amount so in
other words it's the proportion of the
total variation due to between study at
unity so for example thirty percent of
the variation is
two between study differences but what
should we do when we observe that region
18 we can decide and not to pull the
study results as I mentioned before
systematic reviews do not need to
contain a meta-analysis realize that if
studies are not homogenous enough or the
methodology methodological quality of
the include includes papers is too low
it might be better not to pull or we can
decide to account for heterogeneity by
using the random effect model and the
standardized mean difference as we
discussed before and we can explore the
reasons for this heterogeneity for
example conduct subgroup analysis so
what is important is that we need to be
calm when an analysis so for me some
words in English are very difficult and
I'll analyze oxygenate by using the rent
yes sorry I'm a little bit personal but
what I wanted to say with this picture
is that we relied heterogeneity because
it's the added value of meta-analysis of
animal studies so don't worry keep calm
and enjoy especially the new results
which often become available when
analyzing the hedge trinity so do you
remember this plot this was from weaver
at all in 2012 and here we show the
results of the subgroup analysis of the
effects of ischemic preconditioning on
serum creatinine levels and you can see
here that the timing of the intervention
influence results I show that before but
you can also see the effect of ischemic
preconditioning in that's larger in red
standing mice it's however important to
realize again that you should not make
big conclusions based on small
heterogeneous groups subgroup analysis
are often only hypothesis
generating in step 9 we're going to
assess the robustness of the findings
from our meta-analysis in other words
we're going to conduct subgroup analysis
with the aim to assess the robustness of
the results so we asked ourselves the
questions do my results change when I do
things differently if the results change
we should discuss this in the paper for
example and if you change the criteria
for inclusion a little bit so for
example if your results change when you
set the value for a high blood pressure
on a 150 instead of 130 million liters
mercury and it change you need to
discuss that and then we would conclude
that your analysis might not be too
robust but of course we only look at
minor changes and decisions during the
process of conducting your system at
preview finally in step 10 the last step
we check for the presence of publication
bias this is especially important
because the confidence in to observe the
facts in that analysis can be diminished
by unpublished bars of studies in order
to check for publication bias you can
create and interpret of course of funnel
plots here you see a black dot for each
individual study on the x-axis for each
individual study but on the x-axis the
effect size and on the y-axis a measure
of precision in this case the precision
is a 1 divided by the confidence
interval so when a confidence interval
is large very impress itís the dot
appears low in the graph so normally the
dots should be distributed as a funnel
around the effect size like this and am
deviation from the shape can indicate
publication bias in order to estimate
the amount of publication bias we can
impute the possible missing
you can see that on the red side with
the red dots in this case you can see
that especially small studies because
they are low in the grub and you have
low precision so probably right
confidence interval might be missing and
they are not only small but they also
also show a negative effect so an
opposite effect that we then we expected
and this causes often overestimation of
the observed effect size so it's
important to look at publication bias to
make sure if the results you found are
overestimated or not over if there is a
risk for overestimation now it's time to
wrap up and what I really want to make
sure that you remember is that math
analysis can be part of the systematic
review but it does not need to be so and
it's useful to get a quantitative
summary of the evidence it helps us also
to increase power and to explore
heterogeneity between studies it's a
transparent and reproducible process but
be aware as I mentioned before of what a
meta-analysis can and can't do do not
make conclusion based on small
heterogeneous groups the results of
subgroup analysis are always hypothesis
generating and not conclusive last but
not least the quality of a meta-analysis
is completely dependent of the quality
of the primary studies in conclusion
math analysis is useful and fun so keep
calm and review on and especially as
much as possible and if you need help or
you feel the urge to conduct a
systematic review and meta-analysis feel
free to contact us we would love to help
you from circle the systematic review
center for laboratory animal
experimentation thank you so much and I
gave the word back to fun again thank
you well thank you I've got appointments
for that really informative presentation
it's not time for the Q and a question
or a Q&A portion of the talk so if you
had a question you'd like to ask doctor
appointment please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click the send button
will answer as many questions as we have
time for today so let's get started
while we're waiting for questions to
come in I just like to ask dr. Wyman's
like you mentioned heterogeneity and why
we should embrace it and this is kind of
different than what researchers are
probably been told about their data so
you can you elaborate on why we should
embrace heterogeneity and meta-analysis
thank you for that question we should
embrace a virginity because the nature
of animal studies is much more
explorative than for example clinical
studies but it's important that we do
not want too much heterogeneity in a way
that the study still need to be
sufficiently similar but of course when
you conduct a meta-analysis you often
have many types of species already
included so you can expect that's for
example the blood pressure is already a
little bit different in in a rest
compared to a monkey for example and but
the direction of effect so does it
degrees in in all species is informative
so they had originated see per se and
it's not a big problem you need to
embrace it and especially explore it
it's a it's only a problem a lot of
hydrogen 80 when you do not explore it
but again the most important thing is to
realize that you should not compare
apples and oranges in dedicating that
prenups yeah that's a really good point
thank you weirdest we're still waiting
for questions to come on so if you could
can you tell us a little bit more about
the random versus mixed effect models
and is that why you can explore
head urging anymore with the random
model yet he random effect model
probably I can also go back you can you
still go back in my presentation yeah I
can think I can't below yes I would I
will do that one minute if we go back to
that to my spikes sorry one seconds in
what I mentioned before is that in a
random effect model we take into account
two types of variation so random error
and Ryu between study variation so if
you do not take into account the real
differences between studies you
calculate you might calculate an effect
size which is not correct because you
can expect that the effect is not
exactly the same in a mouse and rat or a
rest and and the pig so the most
important difference between the two
models is that more variation is
included and that's mainly because we
calculate the weight of the individual
studies in a different way yeah yeah
that's that's the main thing I think I
showed that I have to look for that
slide the way to stuff a little bit late
probably yes paratus so in the fixed
effect it's only the random error or so
what we assume in a fixed effect model
is that all studies will will try to
estimate exactly the same effect and if
there were differences between the
studies which are always there that's
only do because of sampling error so you
expect that large studies are more
precise than small studies so sampling
error is the only reason why the effect
size might be a little bit different one
from the other whereas in any random
effect model again we assume that there
are real differences between studies so
they all have their own
individual effect size and then we
averaged Oh study so that's that's the
difference okay that's very informative
thank you for that you're welcome um
alright so may I say one more thing so
people I can understand that often my
talk is very difficult is quite
statistical and but don't feel bother to
ask any questions no questions are
stupid and I like to elaborate when
possible because I can understand that
it is sometimes difficult yeah that's
great and if the audience has more
questions they can contact you directly
and that might help too yes so I would
like once again to thank dr. violence
for her presentation do you have any
final comments for the audience no start
reviewing and experience while the
advantage can be as a systematic review
and if you conduct meta-analysis please
don't do that on your own Oscar
statistician or contact us and so to
make sure that you do the right thing
and then you'll see the advantages and
if you have questions please contact me
well that's great it's a great resource
for everybody who wants to do made
analysis certainty once again dr. Hyman
before I want yeah I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for unto me and Huey and
for august of 2016 you receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast is available for replay but
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
web event that's all we have for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon bye